as fall breaks out in canada i'm
reminded of all the beauty innocence and
gun-free fun available from our
neighbors to the north
[Music]
[Applause]
there's the majesty of toronto
[Applause]
vast hockey rinks
[Applause]
and gallons of maple syrup that you can
chug openly and kilt free
for this maple syrup is pure
and nourishing
[Applause]
the changing of the seasons also happens
to be the perfect time to encounter one
of canada's most prized creatures
the artificial intelligence nerd
[Music]
not too long ago these beings were rare
and hidden away in university dungeons
but today they're among the best paid
professionals in the world
together these creatures did something
truly remarkable
without anyone paying much notice they
gave birth to an ai revolution
they turned canada yes canada into one
of the great ai
superpowers this is the story of how all
this came to be
it's the story of one nation's quest to
teach computers to think like humans
it's the story of what this science
experiment will mean for all our lives
and for the future of the human species
so if you're a human
or something try to imitate one
you'll want to pay attention
ah
ever since people first came up with the
idea of computers they've dreamed of
imbuing them with artificial
intelligence
i am a smart fellow
as i have a very fine brain
that's the most remarkable thing i've
ever seen
ai is just a computer that is able to
mimic or simulate uh human thought or
human behavior within that there's a
subset called machine learning that's
now
the underpinning of what is most
exciting about ai
by allowing computers to learn how to
solve problems on their own machine
learning has made a series of
breakthroughs that once seemed nearly
impossible
it's the reason computers can understand
your voice
spot a friend's face in a photo and
steer a car
and it's the reason people are actively
talking about the arrival of human-like
ai
and whether that would be a good thing
or a horrific end-of-day's thing
many people made this moment possible
but one figure towers above the rest
i've come to the university of toronto
to see the man they call the godfather
of modern artificial intelligence
jeff hinton
because of a back condition jeff hinton
hasn't been able to sit down for more
than 12 years
i hate standing i'd much rather sit down
but if i sit down i have a disc that
comes out
sorry
well at least now standing desks are
fashionable and yeah but i was ahead
i was standing where i was standing when
they weren't fashionable
since he can't sit in the car or on a
bus
hinton walks
everywhere
the walk says a lot about hinton and his
result
for nearly 40 years hinton has been
trying to get computers to learn like
people do a quest almost everyone
thought was crazy or at least hopeless
right up until the moment it
revolutionized the field
google thinks this is the future of the
company amazon thinks the future company
apple thinks it's a future company my
own department thinks this stuff's
probably nonsense and we shouldn't be
doing any more
so i took everybody into it except my
own department
chef hinton pretty early on became
obsessed with this idea of figuring out
how the mind
works
he started off getting into physiology
the anatomy of how the brain worked then
he got into psychology
and then finally he settled on more of a
computer science
approach to modeling the brain and got
into artificial intelligence
my feeling is if you want to understand
a really complicated device like a brain
you should build one
i mean you could look at cars and you
could think you could understand cars
when you try and build a car you
suddenly discover that there's this
stuff that has to go under the hood
otherwise it doesn't work yes
[Music]
as jeff was starting to think about
these ideas he got inspired by some ai
researchers across the pond
specifically this guy
frank rosenblatt
rosenblatt
in the late 1950s developed what he
called a perceptron and it was
a neural network a computing system that
would mimic the brain
the basic idea is a collection of small
units called neurons these are little
computing units but they're actually
modeled on the way that the human brain
does its computation
they take incoming data like we do from
our senses and they actually learn so
the neural net can learn to make
decisions over time
rosenblatt's hope was that you could
feed a neural network a bunch of data
like pictures of men and women and it
would eventually learn how to tell them
apart
just like humans do
there was just one problem
it didn't work very well
rosenblatt his neural network was the
single layer of neurons
and it was limited in what it could do
extremely limited
and a colleague of his wrote a book in
the late 60s that showed these
limitations
and it kind of put the whole area of
research into a deep freeze for a good
10 years
no one wanted to work in this area they
were sure it would never work
well
almost no one
it was just obvious to me that it was
the right way to go
the brain's a big neural network and so
it has to be that stuff like this can
work because it works in our brains
there's just never any doubt about that
and what do you think it was inside of
you that
kept you wanting to pursue this when
everyone else was giving up just that
you thought it was the right direction
to go no that everyone else was wrong
okay
[Laughter]
hinton decides he's got an idea of how
these neural nets might work and he's
going to pursue it no matter what
for a little while he's bouncing around
research institutions in the u.s
he kind of gets fed up that most of them
are funded by the defense department and
he starts looking for somewhere else he
can go
he suddenly hears that canada might be
interested in funding artificial
intelligence
and that was very attractive that i
could go off to this civilized town
and just get on with it
so i came to the university of toronto
and then in the mid 80s we discovered
how to make more complicated neural nets
so they could solve those problems that
the simple ones couldn't solve
he and his collaborators developed a
multi-layered neural network a deep
neural network and this started to work
in a lot of ways but again they hit a
ceiling
through the 90s into the 2000s jeff was
one of only a handful of people on the
planet who are still pursuing this
technology
he would show up at academic conferences
and be banished to the back rooms he was
treated as really like a pariah
but jeff was consumed by this and
couldn't stop
he just kept pursuing the idea that
computers could learn
until about 2006 when the world catches
up to hinton's ideas
[Music]
computers were down a lot faster
and now it's behaving like i thought it
would behave in the mid 80s it's solving
everything
the arrival of super fast chips and the
massive amounts of data produced on the
internet gave hinton's algorithms a
magical boost
suddenly computers could identify what
was in an image
then they could recognize speech
and translate from one language to
another
by 2012 words like neural nets and
machine learning were popping up on the
front page of the new york times
next up we have professor jeffrey hinton
of the university of toronto
[Applause]
[Music]
for hinton this is obviously a really
redemptive moment
now he's basically a technology
celebrity
and for canada it's the country's moment
as well
they have more ai researchers than just
about any other place on the planet and
the quest now is to see what these guys
can do starting companies and pushing
the technology forward
i'm going to set out on a journey across
canada to see the best in canadian ai
technology and to get a feel for how far
the technology has come and how far it
still has to go
[Music]
here is a city that gets right at the
central tension of modern life
and the unfolding ai revolution
[Applause]
[Music]
it's montreal
a place filled with beauty and old world
charms
that ask you to move slowly through its
streets
and to chill for a while
reflect
and think deep thoughts
at the same time it's one of the world's
top ai research centers
students flock here from all over the
globe to get deep with machine learning
and to take jeff hinton's ideas and
figure out how to turn them into
products we all use
to see just how successful they've been
look no further than your pocket
all this stuff started out as hardcore
computer science but over the last five
years ai has invaded our everyday lives
your smartphone is packed full of
ai-powered apps including something like
google translate that lets you point
your phone at a magazine that's written
in french and read it as if you were a
local
engineers have been trying to get
computers to translate text like this
for decades but it was jeff's neural
nets that finally made it possible
thanks jeff
and it's not just your smartphone
neural networks are heading for the open
road
off we go
meet my friend stefan the head of
montreal's tesla fan club
i'm driving a tesla for a little bit
more than four years and a half do you
have people asking you for rides all the
time yes
maybe that's because of his fancy pants
autopilot
tesla's semi-autonomous driving system
that kicks in when road conditions are
right
so that's it autopilot's on yes and it's
driving by itself
so we need to pay attention
but we don't have to drive
yeah it's crazy
[Applause]
self-driving cars are packed full of
cameras sensors and radar
when teamed with computer vision neural
nets it's this technology that lets the
cars build a picture of the world
the technology has a long way to go
but this tesla can monitor all the cars
around it switch lanes and park all by
itself
thanks jeff
so you're living in the future
you know when you try it once it's very
difficult
to do without it because i just can be
relaxed
and we can drive like this oops
there's a stop sign that's why we still
need to pay attention
[Music]
a big part of hinton's legacy lies
beyond these examples of ai in the world
he's also inspired a legion of disciples
spreading the good word of neural nets
[Music]
joshua bengio is a professor at the
university of montreal
he's one of the researchers who glommed
on to hinton's ideas when it seemed to
make little sense to do
so over the years he's formed a mind
meld with hinton
and together they've come up with many
of the key concepts behind modern ai
you guys worked on this stuff through
the 80s 90s the 2000s and then it just
seemed like this totally went from
computer science and research to we see
it everywhere in our lives are you you
know are even you surprised what's
happened the last five years that it
really is like sitting on all our phones
and the rate at which
the progress and the industrial products
have been coming out
is totally something we didn't expect
even now it's hard to predict where are
we going is it going to slow down
[Music]
or are we going to continue with this
exponential increase
[Music]
it's thanks to yahshua that montreal is
full of top-notch ai graduate talent
this in turn has brought tech giants
like google and facebook to tao
along with their ample checkbooks
to me it seems like if you're good at ai
you can make two three hundred thousand
dollars a year
this is crazy to see how much these guys
get paid now a million dollars is
something quite common as a salary have
you ever had a country offer you an
incredible money to come
set up a lab there not a country but
yeah companies you know
[Music]
but yahshua has rejected the lucrative
offers of big neural net
he remains committed to the ivory towers
of academia which is a better fit for
his philosophical approach to ai
you've got guys like elon musk and
stephen hawking that sometimes paint
this technology in a very very dark
light that it could run amok and start
doing things on its own
what do you feel when you hear people
say things like that i'm not concerned
about technology running amok of the
terminator scenario i think is not very
credible and i also believe that if
we're able to build machines that are
as smart as us they're also smart enough
to understand our values and to
understand our moral system and and so
act in a way that's good for us
now
i think there are real concerns which is
essentially misuse of ai to influence
people's minds it's already happening
with political advertising yeah i mean
we've already seen like the stuff from
facebook so i think we should be careful
about this
and try to regulate the use of ai
in places where it's morally wrong
ethically wrong i think we just should
just ban it and make it you know illegal
it's comforting that joshua has these
concerns
but hop down the road from the
university in reality or what's left of
it becomes messier
this tiny room is the home to a startup
called lyrebird
it was founded by yahshua's former
students
and has built an app that can clone your
voice
are you speaking about this new
algorithm to copy voices
this is huge they can make us say
anything now really anything
[Music]
one of its founders is this guy mexican
expat jose
he taught me the art of the clone
so you'll need to record yourself for a
few minutes of audio
thousands of letters danced across the
amateur author's screen
when you start to eat like this
something is the matter
you guys better quit politics and take
in washing
i don't know where that one came from
okay so create my digital voice now
creating your digital voice takes at
least one minute one minute my god yeah
so
before to create some artificial voice
of someone you would need to record
yourself for at least eight hours
test your voice all right so now i get
to type something yeah so the moment of
the truth okay
once liarbird's ai has worked its magic
after i'm done typing oh better spell
better
any words i put into the app can be
played back in my digital voice
and here's the crazy thing
even words i never actually said in the
first place
artificial intelligence technology seems
to be advancing very quickly should we
be afraid
i mean i can definitely hear my voice in
there that's that is that's really
interesting i just picked those words at
random and i definitely did not say some
of them and it's like flawless and being
able to sort of pick from just about any
word and manufacture it
[Music]
hello world is the best joy i have ever
seen
[Music]
this technology seems sweet
[Music]
but lends itself to all manner of
trickery
[Applause]
i've popped back to my hotel to test out
the library technology a little bit
and you can see some really obvious ways
that this could be abused
this is this is fake donald trump
talking
the united states is considering
in addition to other options topping all
trade with any country doing business
with north korea
and then you can picture somebody taking
over your voice and creating some mayhem
in your personal life
now to really put my computer voice to
the test i am going to call
my dear sweet mother and see if she
recognizes me
hey mom hi what are you guys up to today
um well it's saturday we didn't have any
electricity early this morning and we're
just hanging around the house i'm just
finishing up work and waiting for the
boys to get home
okay
i think i'm coming down with a virus
oh why you feel mad
i was messing around with you you were
talking to a computer
i felt like i was talking to you it's
amazing
is that scary or good
it could be scary if it was something
really important
but you know with the dash
i don't know
[Music]
it sounds like you
is it
[Music]
yes
[Music]
the real artificial intelligence weirdos
in canada live here
in edmonton
[Music]
this is a large but very very cold and
very very flat city that is more or less
in the middle of nowhere
it's the kind of place that has a giant
butter vault
to help people survive the lean winter
months
canadians like to put the best possible
spin on how these conditions bring out
interesting traits in
people ask anyone
like this guy from the edmonton tourist
center
well edmonton's uh one of those cities
that isn't you know automatically listed
in the top cities in canada in terms of
size or scale or or
notice even but it's always had a really
neat quality to it
of that western independent spirit that
you see very much in in alberta in
general combined with a conscience and
a thoughtfulness
over at the university of alberta some
of the most far-out ai research in the
world is taking place
the man i'm here to see is the
university's very own ai godfather
rich sutton
rich is considered one of the great
revolutionary thinkers in a.i
[Music]
you are not canadian
i am canadian you are
but not by birth no i was born in the
u.s but uh now i'm just canadian okay
and what brought you to canada the
politics i wanted to get away from
difficult times in the united states the
united states was invading other
countries in 2003 when i came here
and i didn't care for all that
sutton entered the field of ai in the
mid-80s
and like jeff hinton and joshua bengio
he was a big believer in neural networks
sutton has a different idea about how to
further the technology
unlike hinton's method of feeding neural
networks reams and reams of data and
telling them what to do
sutton wants them to learn more
naturally from experience an approach
called reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning it's like when
animals do and what people do you try
several things the things that work best
you keep doing those and things that
don't work out so well you stop doing
them and how do you teach your computer
um well all you need is
all you need is a sense the computer has
to have a sense of what's good and
what's bad
and so you give it a special signal
called the reward if the reward is high
that means it's good the reward is low
that means it's bad
to see reinforcement learning in action
i found marlos an industrious young
brazilian who's created an ai to play
his video games for him
his algorithm plays the game thousands
of times
and gradually learns from experience how
to do better
so the goal of this game is that you are
this yellow blob then what you have to
do is that you have to get as many
potions as you can while avoiding
harpies
and this is like the ai going at this
for the first time it's the i run it for
the first time so it just bumps into
things if it gets points it's happy if
it dies it's unhappy yes
and the guy starts to figure out that
maybe what i want to do is to collect
these potions and avoid the harpies and
now we can look at ai that has ran for
five thousand games okay and this is
what it looks like
you can tell that it's smarter about its
strategy yes
then what happens if you run it 500 000
times oh we we got to the super human
performance level
though notching a high score is the
noblest of pursuits reinforcement
learning has turned out to have all
kinds of other applications
it's behind the algorithm that
recommends movies and tv shows on
netflix and amazon
it beat the world champion go player a
feat previously thought impossible for a
computer
[Music]
soon it could read your brain waves and
determine whether you have a mental
disorder
but for sutton all that is just the
beginning
we are trying to make real intelligence
we're trying to recreate human
intelligence humans are our example
he sees reinforcement learning as the
path to what futurists call the
singularity
the moment when our ai creations light
up and surge past human level
intelligence
do you have a date for the singularity
or so they give you it's a it's a quite
broad probability distribution and the
median is at 20 40. 20. that means equal
chance being before or after 2040. okay
the rationale goes like this uh by 2030
we'll have the hardware
so give guys like me another 10 years to
figure out
the algorithms yeah software to go with
the hardware
to do it
it's going to be exciting where we're
going
if 2040 seems like a long time to wait
to meet a smart robot do not fret
[Music]
over in the experimental wing of the
university there are co-eds hard at work
blurring the line between humans and
machines
are you
human of course not
but that shouldn't keep us from chatting
case in point homegrown edmontonian
genius corey matthewson
tell me about this guy a little bit or
yeah
sure
so this is blueberry
uh on blueberry i've deployed the
improv system so there's an artificial
improv system running on blueberry right
now
yes that's right
corey does improv comedy with a robot
i've been doing improv longer than i've
been doing computing science i've been
doing it for 12 years and i thought you
know there's no more natural convergence
than taking some of these
state-of-the-art systems and putting
them up on stage
one day we'll make it to the moon if
this planet
is not to be our last
it is the sky in the moon of the
universe the sun the sun
the sky the moon and the universe the
sun the sun
the sky the moon i keep thinking it was
like a ventriloquist sort of this is
like a new age
that's a really good way to put it like
a strange twist on it the piece that's
different is that i don't know what it
will say
blueberry i i created you i downloaded a
voice into your brain so that you could
perform in front of these people
but i do not know what i'm going to say
i don't know what you're going to say
either
to give blueberry the power of surreal
canadian improv corey made use of some
tech that should be familiar by now
a neural network
step one he feeds the network to
dialogue from a bunch of movies
102 000 movies to be exact
all the movies every movie for a hundred
years
and that's just so he can
learn language see how somebody responds
to somebody else that's exactly right
yeah it builds kind of a language model
step two he uses reinforcement learning
to train the network rewarding it when
it makes sense and punishing it when it
spits out gibberish
time to put this wannabe kid in the hall
to the test
there we go
start improvising
okay
campers we're gonna get ready for a real
baseball game grab your gloves and grab
your baseball bats and let's get out
there especially you franklin
of course i will not be much longer okay
okay well
why aren't you ready for the match
i do not have any more good news if i
were your boyfriend
okay
come on franklin you know how i feel
about you but you got to keep your head
in the game right now
you will see if you do not stop here
when you go what have you done
it's friday yeah i i know how to teach
you what the character of your team is
going to do oh jesus put down the bat
franklin what are you doing you have
nothing to hide that song
i i've got nothing to hide look this is
all i am
okay
that's great
obviously some of the responses are a
little bit weird but then it's really
funny because then as you're going along
it did hit a couple of things perfectly
and and then it's like
yeah i mean it's extra hilarious because
of course
blueberry may not be ready for its
second city audition just yet but corey
has a higher purpose
making a.i relatable
there is a fear
in society of ai
so we are kind of humanizing this ai
we're we're taking it down a peg we're
saying don't be afraid of this tech look
at how cute it is look at how kind of
naive it is yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
isn't there a flip side to that though
then you make it cute and and then
people start to accept it and yeah you
know then then we wake up
i mean i
i don't think that will happen in my
time
the singularity may be near
or it may be not so near
but if the inhabitants of this oddly
beautiful place keep pushing the
technology they just might create
something alarmingly human-like one day
for rich sutton it's not a question of
whether we'll get there but whether
we'll be able to accept our mechanized
brethren
our society will be will be challenged
you know it's just like every time you
know our black people people
are women people we will do the same
thing with robots eventually
uh
are they allowed to own property are
they allowed to earn an income or do
they have to be owned by someone
but a robot's obviously not a person
[Laughter]
right
now
[Music]
for my last stop i returned to toronto
home to 2.8 million people one very tall
tower
and of course the godfather himself
inside the system
there's lots of little processes which
are a little bit like brain cells
he may be an import but jeff hinton has
done something truly exceptional for
toronto
he's turned this city into an ai mecca
where ai conferences like this one seem
to take place daily we are enormously
thankful to canadians for inventing all
this stuff because we now use it
throughout our entire business
we have it on record that he owes that
google owes canada
absolutely okay
that was a mistake
the tech industry is full of people who
adore ai
and then also some famous types like
elon musk and stephen hawking who said
well that ai might be the end of us
to consider such dystopia in the proper
light
i've come to toronto's geekiest bar
hello george
to encase myself in this steel container
with george devorsky
he's a writer for gizmodo and an ai
philosopher
[Music]
well since we're in the apocalyptic
bar what is the
the con case around ai what what's
what's the nastiest scenario that
everybody's worried about unfortunately
there's there's no shortage of nasty
scenarios and this i think this is what
makes artificial intelligence such a
scary thing is all the different ways
that it can go wrong it can be
everything from an accident you know
where we just didn't think it through we
gave a very powerful computer
instructions to do something we thought
we explained it articulately we thought
we gave it a concrete goal and it
completely took a different path than we
thought it would in such a way that it
actually caused some great damage
i'm sure you've heard the old paperclip
example
where you're a paperclip manufacturer
and you say hey we need lots of
paperclips and because the artificial
intelligence has so much reach and so
much power it actually starts to go
about converting all of the matter and
all the molecules on the planet into
paper clips before you know it we've now
converted the entire cosmos into
paperclips
it's a crazy scenario but it's an
illustrative scenario we can't be
dismissive of the perils i think that's
exceptionally dangerous
and i don't think it's too early to
start raising the alarm bells about it
being turned into clippy sounds awful
but fear not
we'll have years to ease into that sort
of suffering
as ai steadily plucks off one job after
another
[Music]
the first to go of course will likely be
the always screwed factory workers
which brings us to suzanne gildert
a budding ai overlord and founder of
robotics startup kindred ai
[Music]
tell me about these guys so these are
research prototypes
so they're some of the first robots we
built at kindred
we tend to work with small robots it's a
bit like if you imagine a child growing
up and it breaks a lot of things now
imagine if the child was six feet tall
when it had the brain of a six month old
it would be terrible
terribly dangerous how many of these
robots have ever slapped you i have been
hit in the face by robots a couple of
times
suzanne seems nice enough
she makes exotic digital art
and she loves cats to the point where
she's built a robotic fleet of them for
the office
this one i believe is called pink foot
it's a quadruped robot loosely based on
a cat anatomy although it's not a very
highly faithful representation yeah
and then when you were growing up you
would build things as well yeah that's
correct yeah
so i was really enthralled by
electronics at an early age
i guess most little girls would be
looking at trays of beads and things and
i was looking at trays of like resistors
and capacitors and little components but
having the same kind of reaction to them
[Music]
but don't be fooled by the hobby
electronics and the cute catbots
[Music]
suzanne is a keen businesswoman
and kindred has recently embarked on its
first commercial venture
what's going on here is we have a bank
of robots that are learning so they are
continuously running uh picking up
objects
these would run all day all day all
night
powered by a neural network these arms
can do something that's very easy for a
human but very hard for a bot
pick up objects of different shapes
and put them down
most factories still use people to do
that sort of thing
lots and lots of people
today everyone's shopping on e-commerce
thousands and thousands of different
types of objects shapes textures weights
how do you pick that up
right now it's humans you have millions
of humans in warehouses just like
picking up things and putting it into
another location so we're teaching our
robots how to do that
what's the hard part it's figuring out
what's a belt what's a shirt or it's
just how to grasp it yeah exactly it's
very hard to pick it up right so so
things will show up in any shape right
and you got to figure out how to pick it
up without dropping it
put it in the location so it takes a lot
of training
of that training involves of all things
humans
robot pilots who manually control the
arms while the ai watches and learns the
finer points of grabbing
[Music]
isn't there something grim about the
human training there
and yeah it's not good to take people's
jobs away but this kind of technology
coming into the workforce should make us
start thinking about how we're going to
pay people in the future because ai is
not just going to automate you know
manual labor jobs it's going to automate
things like doctors and lawyers and
accountants very soon so i think there's
going to be issues there's going to be a
lot of disruption
suzanne is a realist
but she's also an optimist
in her vision of the future robots won't
be mindless competitors to humanity
they'll be full-fledged citizens like
the rest of us
one of the crazy ideas i see you talk
about was you've got a robot and
it's working in a factory and then it's
gotta go maybe it gets paid a wage and
it goes to buy lithium ion batteries to
keep it going why would that have to
happen i mean for having a physical body
they will have a lot of physical needs
just like we have
[Music]
you might have to go to their repair
shop to get like a motor looked out or
something like that and they'll have to
pay someone to do that i think they'll
just be contributing to our economy in
the same way we do
and if they have brains like us they'll
want to explore new things they've never
seen before they'll want to learn things
they'll want to perhaps rest so that
their mind has time to consolidate all
this new information i keep trying to
picture it in my head though so this is
the robot
worker does he go home and sit on the
couch and watch tv after work and he's i
don't see why not i probably watch cat
videos
it's hard to tell sometimes if suzanne
is laughing with us or at us
but she's not alone in her cautious
optimism for the future
i think there's always a sense that you
know technology can be either used for
good or used for bad
i'm reassured that that canada is part
of it in terms of trying to set us on
the right path
on the whole
being responsible and thoughtful about
the power we're gaining by research and
learning
is the right trend line and i don't
think ai's automatically doomed to some
dystopian outcome
[Music]
we're told that politicians will come up
with policies that address massive job
loss and prevent horrific inequality
between the classes
and we're told that these guys will take
so long to become human-like that we
need not be afraid for a while
[Applause]
the truth though is that we're turning
ourselves over to the unknown here
so you know
fingers crossed
eventually
i think we will become
the ais
we will become the
intelligent machines
we will understand how things can be
smart and we can deliberately create
them
so it's you might think of it as making
a new generation new kinds of people
humanity is continuing to evolve
and why wouldn't enhanced people or even
design people
be
the next step in humanity
[Music]
it's really hard to predict the future
i think there's going to be all sorts of
things happen we didn't expect
[Music]
but there's one thing we can predict
this technology is going to change
everything
[Music]
goodbye
goodbye
goodbye goodbye
once i power you down that's it
and if you do not mind i'll never see
you again
yeah
that's right
we'll end it right there
it was getting deep that was getting
really deep